if I read a script that I feel like
hella okay if I read it if I read
whenever you descripted I feel like is a
story or a role that is something I have
to do or I want to be a part of it's a
feeling of like claustrophobia or
pressure at first and like a feeling of
that I need to be a part of it and then
thinking you know what the audition
process going to be and and how do I get
as close to this goal as possible
because as we all know the answer is
more often know than it is a yes but you
know I said this to a friend recently
like getting very close to a role or
getting a lot of callbacks or being one
of the last three but then not getting
it that is not a clear loss there's a
feeling of an overnight switch with some
of these films but it's been an even
more gratifying feelings or working with
producers or directors that I've worked
with before in the past and more than
anything more than a one random
successful audition I think just as
consistently putting out as much good
work as possible
in audition form and casting form is a
step in the right direction
I think honesty and being as open a book
as possible I think that was the biggest
takeaway from the drama high school I
went to for me was keep your heart in
the sleeve as an actor that's your
instrument your ability to make yourself
an open wound is what we'll communicate
to the audience and hopefully serve as a
therapeutic device for people experience
something experiencing something similar
to the story and I think that's true of
call me by our name and we just did the
interview with Daniel Kuya and an answer
to have get out as well as it relates to
working more professionally and outside
of a academically dramatic environment I
think it's adaptability that's like the
strongest suit you can have as an actor
the experience working with Luca
Guadagnino is different than the
experience working with Greta Gerwig was
different than the experience working
with Christopher Nolan and as an actor
particularly if you're not the leader of
the project you try to make yourself as
clay-like as malleable as possible
a blip in the radar a Wallflower
somebody who comes prepared and is ready
to go and maybe have an idea or trick up
your sleeve something you want to try
out but ultimately responsibilities to
the characters or the story to that
sequel
that day and just trying to do the best
job as possible I think now in the
method II sense I don't think a
relationship has to mirror what's on
screen necessarily and I think if your
characters don't know one another that
could be helpful to have a a guardedness
or an awkwardness or a wall present in
the scene but if you're working with
someone intimately it's good to have
that chemistry just from a perspective
of you know wanting to try things out as
an actor and feeling comfortable and not
feeling like the person opposite II was
going to be judging you which can sound
silly or something but you know it's a
game of sensitivity and the more
sensitive you can make yourself and more
more able to communicate usually so
comforts important and and also I think
a working relationship and and you know
the hopefully the emotional IQ and to
know when to step away if you're seeing
partners having a tough time of things
or knowing a word of encouragement can
be used knowing what not to say but
ultimately trying to be the greatest
ensemble member as possible keeping in
mind that it's a marathon and not a
sprint and particularly if you are one
of the leads on a project they you know
you're tone setter of sorts so you can't
exclusively be concerned about your
performance and actually often your
performance is aided if you can put your
collective conscious on somebody else in
the scene or on the story or on the
script and not you know what's happening
to that line or what inflection you want
to use or what have you that's what
makes me want to be an artist so so what
makes me want to be an actor is that
feeling a flow and like I heard someone
say to me once before like he can be
stapling papers or it can be playing the
piano or it could be acting I think when
you lose yourself when you find that
certain feeling that's just exciting and
more exciting then you know being at
home eight hours before you do the scene
and thinking that's the scene that I
that I feel that climax and lose myself
in but rather you know you're in the
middle the scene and and in no cheesy
way but just feeling like oh I don't
know what happened there that was truth
force or spontaneous and and working
from that perspective which is
admittedly easier the more you work
because like I remember like Craig juh
Leslie who directed I time
he put me in my first pilot ever one of
my first jobs I remember the audition I
had for him I think I had three lines
and like a three-page scene so I don't
really have much the same as a family
scene
I memorized where each family member in
the room was so in this audition my neck
was stepping around you know for the
first couple takes you like you know you
just look at the reader and you know
pretending there are people everywhere
so like I you know you know them
starting outside like I want to know
exactly what I was doing in advance and
and memorize the other dialogue and
scene and what other people were doing
like the scene when mr. Perlman at the
end of call me by her name is a huge
speech and I usually really like to know
what the posting dialogue is just for a
rhythm of the scene and to know the
pacing but that was one right you know I
think I knew maybe wouldn't women's last
lines were but I really wanted to
experience it and hear it on the day and
have a natural moment with it and not
not know exactly what was coming I could
have told myself it would be I don't
know I think it's a it's a lesson that I
I feel like I learned early on but it's
one that I try to keep as personal as
possible I don't think it's exclusive to
entertainment and to to filmmaking I
think it's in any collaborative process
that it's often not personal a negative
note someone being brash and the way
they're giving you a note it's you're
it's a team effort
so there's because like I said you want
to keep yourself open and sensitive when
you're working at least I try to but you
have to and that and that can be this
can be not I feel like a parent at a
young age but there has to be like
professional you work you thick-skinned
ready to get whatever note really comes
at you and then there's personally which
you protect and helps you protect the
work you and I think you keep those
things separate and I guess that was I
had a good year in drama high score I
felt like I did a scene poorly a number
of times where I feel like I can get
over being bad and yet before that I was
really like a very very sensitive about
performance and notes and
and would take things personally when
really I mean the whole point and the
tension as an actor is you know your
body your voice your physicality is your
instrument and yet it's not personal so
he gives you a note or you're not
clicking you're not getting you seen in
a certain way
[Music]